-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy- and Golden Globe
nominated actor
you know from "The Outsiders
and "Wayne's world"
and shows such as
"The West Wing" and
"Parks and Recreation."
He stars in "9-1-1: Lone Star,
which airs Monday nights on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Rob Lowe.
How are you, Rob?
-Hey, Seth!
Gosh! It's been forever.
Good to see you again.
-It has been a very long time.
How have you held up
during our pandemic year?
-I mean, my ice-cream addictio
has gotten out of control.
But I'm going to rehab.
So it's going to be good.
I plan to fight it.
I'm going to fight it.
-Well, I think that everybody,
as they've watched your body
not change
for the last 30 years,
we definitely have thought
"There's a guy
who eats too much ice cream.
-[ Laughs ] Well, you know
I try to keep my act together.
And I want this COVID thin
to be over like the rest of us
I'm lucky that I've been abl
to work and shoot the show
I've had more nasal swabs
than any human
should be subjected to.
There should be a Geneva code,
I would think.
-A lot of swabbing.
A lot of swabbing over here,
as well.
This show must be fun to do.
I want to ask, one,
about the show,
but I also want to ask
how it is --
your son is a writer
on the show.
-Yes.
-That's so cool.
-My son actually
started writing --
working with Ryan Murphy
before I did.
And then when this --
When we teamed up
to do "9-1-1: Lone Star,"
they were like, "Wait a minute
Shouldn't we actually have
Rob Lowe's son writing on a show
about a father and a son?"
So they switched him over
from "American Horror Story"
where he was originally,
and now he just wrote
our last crossover episode
where all the shows
came together,
and it was our biggest episode
of the year.
-Did either of you
have any trepidation about
working together,
or was it just pure enthusiasm
-I actually lo-- I thought
it would be great, actually.
And it's --
I've got to tell you, as a dad
it's been so fun when he'll come
and give me a note
and the note will be great
because he's a smart littl
whipper-snapper.
And I don't even realize
it's my own son.
And then I walk away,
I go, "Wait a minute!
I used to change
that kid's diapers!
What the hell's goin' on?"
-I do want to give him credi
because --
He's obviously
a wonderful TV writer,
but we've talked about
how he trolls your Instagram
and that might be some
of my favorite writing of his.
Here's one
you posted of yourself
and you wrote, "Backyard vibes."
And then your son wrote,
"You're this close
to losing phone privileges."
-[ Laughter ]
-I like that one.
There's this -- There was
a "West Wing," and he wrote,
"We all know you don't kno
how to play chess."
But this, Rob --
this is the kill shot.
You wrote, "I love that ancestry
connects my passions of history,
family, and storytelling,"
and your son wrote,
"I used it to find out tha
my real dad was John Stamos.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, those are all A-plus
-Right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's -- Well,
I'm glad you think he's funny,
'cause we were taking out
a big comedy pitch this week
So I have
the Seth Meyers approval.
I love this.
-Great. Yes, please.
Feel free to drop my name
if you think
it's at all helpful
in any pitches.
But this is --
This show, "9-1-1,"
this is obviously not a comedy
You play a New York firema
transplanted to Austin, Texas.
And are you enjoying
doing this show?
It seems like an incredibl
meaty part to be playing.
-Yeah, I'm loving it. And I'm --
Look, we all know how hard it is
to be in a show
that actually works
and people -- that's a hit
And that's fun.
I've got to tell you.
It's really fun
that it's been embraced.
And I think there's somethin
about playing real-life heroes
first responders in a time
where we're so grateful
that they're actually out there.
And I love doing that.
I love that it's physical.
I love that the tone
is so weird.
Like, it's a Ryan Murphy
version, you know?
It's not your parents'
"Emergency!"
And that keeps it
really fun for me.
-You mentioned
that it's really physical.
How have you done with
the physical challenges
of pretending to be a fireman?
-As you know, I can preten
to do many things.
-Yeah.
-But don't ask me
to actually save anybody
or do anything for real.
But when it comes to fake stuff,
I'm so good at it.
-[ Laughter ]
-You know, so...
I think that
I was kind of born --
[ Laughs ]
I was born to play this fireman.
I definitely look way more
realistic doing it than I feel
-Yeah.
You also became a podcaste
during this past year.
"Literally! With Rob Lowe"
is your podcast.
And, you know,
this is both in reference
to your "Parks and Rec"
character,
but also a chance for you
to sort of do
some longer-form talking stuff
Have you enjoyed it?
-I loved it.
I have to say
I thought I might like it,
and it turns out
I really love it.
And whether it's getting,
you know, people
that have been
in the public eye forever
that I've known
in a different way
like Gwyneth Paltrow or Pratt,
Chris Pratt, you know.
It's being able to talk to the
and about them
in a way
that other people probably can't
because they don't have
that history.
And it's been awesome.
I love it.
I love the long-form
conversation.
-You mentioned Pratt.
I think that "Parks and Rec,
as well as "The West Wing" -
I should note you have two shows
that I think provided
great comfort to people,
especially this last year
when everyone was looking
for things to watch.
People must always want to kno
if you are still in touch
with those two casts.
-Yeah.
I am in touch more I would say
with the "Parks and Rec" cast,
and I think that's probabl
a function of that it's --
It wasn't 20 -- "West Wing
is almost 20 years ago.
-That's crazy.
-That's insane to say that
But I was just texting
with one of the writers
on the staff, Aaron.
I hosted a big "Chicago 7" panel
for Aaron Sorkin,
who I continue to adore.
And so whenever I see
any of the gang
from either show,
it's always great.
But it's really hard
when everybody's so busy.
-Yeah, and on the other hand
it's also good
that everybody is busy,
and we certainly appreciat
that you made time for us
on your schedule.
It's always great
to see you, Rob.
-Yeah, you too.
You're killing it.
Keep up the good work.
-I'll tell you who's
killing it, is your son.
You go sell that comedy pitch.
-I'm gonna go sell it, baby!
-Okay.
If you don't sell it,
it's on you.
'Cause he's the star.
-Not on him. It'll be on me.
-"9-1-1: Lone Star"
airs Monday nights on Fox.